this is the last in a series of four
workshops brought to you by the alumni
consulting team and the public
management program both programs of the
Center for Social Innovation just a
quick word about each of them the alumni
consulting team is an estimated to be
one of the largest pro bono resource
providers in the Bay Area and provides
an estimated value of more than 1
million dollars in pro bono management
consulting service annually to the
nonprofit community through a network of
GSB alumni and student volunteers for
over three decades the public management
program has prepared the next generation
of social sector leaders by giving MBA
students the knowledge and experience
necessary to apply business principles
to social and environmental issues the
PMP remains the first and only Business
School in the nation to offer a
certificate in public management as I
said both of these programs are programs
of the Center for social innovation an
umbrella organization that's committed
to promoting effective and efficient
solutions to social problems in the
United States and around the world
now I'd like to introduce our moderator
William F Mian bill is the chairman of
the West Coast practice of McKinsey and
company during his 24 years with the
firm bill has had extensive experience
working with chief executives and senior
managers of a wide range of businesses
in New York asia-pacific and the western
United States in addition to his private
sector experience he has extensive
experience working with many nonprofits
in philanthropy health care education
the arts the environment Public
Television and economic death
economic development he is on the board
of many many nonprofit organizations
including the San Francisco Symphony
philanthropic research incorporated and
the organs Shakespeare Festival just to
name a few he currently is the chair of
the board for the United Way of the Bay
Area we are proud to have bill as a CSI
lecturer and strategic management here
at the GSB and as our resident expert on
nonprofit board governance
as a BA in English and comparative
literature from Columbia University and
an MBA from none other than the GSB in
fact this year marks his 25th reunion
from the GSB and as a p.m. here I cannot
imagine a better slate of experts to
share this issue to explore this issue
with you this evening
so please join me in walking welcoming
this esteemed panel Thank You Julie I
think I the real reason I'd facilitate
these panels is that I have Julie get to
introduce me once every year or so I
never think more highly of myself than
when Julie introduces me a couple of
quick notes of introduction I'm going to
just very briefly introduce our very
distinguished panel and I'll ask each of
our panel members to introduce
themselves a little bit more depth when
they begin their remarks on my left of
course is John morgridge who you know
probably most prominently is the
chairman of Cisco but also extensively
involved in the nonprofit and
philanthropic sectors next is Kavita
Ram Dass who is president CEO of the
Global Fund for women and I think we've
learned on these panels it's always best
if we actually have the leader of a
non-profit represent their point of view
on government governance in addition to
we volunteer board members and all the
way to my at the end of my left is Bob
Fisher a longtime executive at the gap
and now on the board of directors and
with extensive involvement primarily an
environmental nonprofits
I'm gonna start out just by asking each
of our panel members will be speaking
for about 10 minutes each and then we'll
leave plenty of time for questions no
need to write them on an index card but
we'll be taking questions until probably
7:15 a little bit
longer if you would like I usually start
out of these things with just trying to
orient us all with a few of what I call
the nine attributes of best practices
for nonprofit governance if my
overarching theme is that if you give me
any set of hard and fast rules for
nonprofit governance I will find a
nonprofit which violates every single
one which is well governed and I will
find you one that at least on the face
adheres to those hard and fast rules
very well and is not very well governed
at all having said that I do think there
are a few principles and I'll just share
three or four of of my nine and perhaps
the first one is the most important one
which is I think well govern nonprofits
have an ambitious mission which is
clearly identified in my MBA class which
now includes about 65 students every
year the MBAs are assigned the task of
going to find the mission for a
nonprofit and to evaluate it and in
virtually every year we conclude that
probably 80 or 85% of those mission
statements for those nonprofits have a
significant lack by some relatively you
know thoughtful criteria and so I just
think it's very hard for a government
for a governing body to be effective for
a non-profit if the mission is not clear
if it isn't ambitious if it isn't
something that actually does energize
them and the nonprofit themselves and I
think it's it's one of those things
that's perfectly obvious and and and far
too rare that nonprofit board to
actually just start with a profound
thinking through their mission many of
the questions you hear about nonprofit
governance have to do with the mechanics
how big should a non-profit board be is
perhaps the most common question and the
answer is 22 people
there is no good answer to that question
and I have seen a lot of people have a
prejudice against large boards and I
think that there are any number of very
very effective large boards and again
there are some very small boards you
know five six or twelve people that are
not very effective there's no question
that larger boards are require more
discipline more process but I have a
couple of guidelines I think all
effective boards have a small group of
truly committed leaders if it's a 4 to
12 or 15 it's probably no more than 3 or
4 people if you have a board of 15
people with 4 people who are really
deeply committed and energized and and
spend a lot of time you're a very
fortunate organization if you have a
board of 75 or 80 it's probably 12 or 15
and perhaps that's represented in an
executive committee it doesn't always
have to be but but for sure you can
identify those people by name and for me
that the test is a relatively simple one
which is for those people this activity
is their number one non work non family
activity and I think that that's almost
just a minimum test in terms of how
large a board can be I really don't
think there's a simple test my rule of
thumb is that a board can have up to 10
or 15% not active members and still be a
vital board and not active meaning by
you know simple rules of work wealth and
wisdom are they generous personally do
they help in the development process do
they bring the skills that they're on
the board to bring do they show up do
they care and you're never going to get
particularly on a large board below ten
or fifteen percent in active members
because there's always a few people
you've asked on who turned out not to be
able to deliver against their commitment
or you made a mistake or their 87 years
old and it's just more pragmatic to
allow them to continue in their
at that time so I really think that's
the simplest test for the size of the
board and there are many boards
performing art boards perhaps most
prominently we're for development
purposes diversity purposes constituency
purposes it makes a lot of sense to have
a larger board it obviously means that
you have to have very disciplined
committee processes we're much if not
most of the important work of the board
is going to go on and you certainly need
an executive committee that's high
functioning with that size of a board
the last thing I'll point out is I think
effective boards have a process and a
systematic way to engage the board in
what I call the thing itself there are a
lot of boards you go and you just wonder
sometimes what you are the board of you
go through the fans committee report and
you go through the nominating committee
report and you go through the marketing
report and you go through this report
and that report and it could be anything
and in fact most of us are involved in
nonprofit because we care deeply about
the thing itself and it could be the
environment it could be music it could
be teaching kids to read it could be
helping older people it could be any of
a range of things and I think effective
boards in a very disciplined way at the
board meetings and outside of board
meetings make sure that the board
members feel like they're very much in
touch with the reason that they're there
in the first place if you're a symphony
board member you want to see a musician
or a musician director if you're on a
board helping older people you'd like to
actually spend some time with older
people if you're supporting
underprivileged families you should have
a family that's been helped if you're
teaching kids to read you should have
some kids who've learned to read as a
result of this program actually come to
the board meetings and I think that that
would be much more energizing than the
next 15 minutes of the report from the
Finance Committee so there are many
other things that I think can contribute
to an effective board but those are sort
of my top three or four just trying to
frame this again I think we have a
terrific panel and John we look forward
to your comments thank you how many of
you are board members of an
so we've got a lot of advice well I've
always found these financial reports the
most intriguing that by stating that I
think that one of the real values of
diversity on a board is that different
people find different parts of the board
activity intriguing and it's been
amazing to me I think many boards have
had kind of a policy of diversification
but within the last since the spotlight
has been put on business within the last
two years
the boards that I'm on and I'm on some
national boards I'm on some university
boards I'm on some local boards but I
would say half of them now we get a
spreadsheet with all of the capabilities
lifts listed all the terms listed what
what their area of expertise is and I
think it's a real I think that's
important because there should be
someone that's interested in the
financial report and what it indicates
and what the budget is for the coming
year because the quickest way for a
non-profit to get in trouble is to spend
money they don't have or spend money
that doesn't become part of it
last year I was on a national board and
I should have known better they came
forward with a budget that was ten
percent over the prior year's budget
there was no business that was planning
to grow ten percent in the past this
past year there just wasn't any I looked
at a board I am on the local board that
came in with a budget a couple of months
ago that had an 18% increase for next
year how many people in the room
leave that you can raise 18% more in the
coming July - July than you raised this
year I just don't think it's going to
happen and yet if someone's not
interested guess what those budgets gets
passed when you when you speak about the
United Way there's been some real
financial challenges you know a lot of
the united united way's excepted
designated giving but they didn't budget
get designated giving and they got in a
lot of trouble because they continued to
give up to the top 100 as they had for
the past decade and guess what the money
came in and it wasn't designated that
way it was designated to a lot of other
organizations so I think the key thing
in terms of one of the key things in
governance is having diverse board with
a lot of varied interests and
backgrounds and that's true of a
business board also and that reason you
know in the same vein almost every
nonprofit the number one challenge is
fundraising and so it's got to be you
have to have a body a group that that
takes that on with with enthusiasm
because it's a tough job I think the
second thing that that's important in
board governments is to be sensitive to
for change
you know most of most of the board's I
sit on particularly the local boards are
products of an inspired individual and
they have a vision and that vision is is
the driving force for that group but
changes is impacting and it's impacting
all nonprofits and change always is an
opportunity most of us don't look at it
that way and maybe in some cases it
isn't I don't know but
in the vast majority of cases change is
a is a real driver and I think people
who come out of the business world have
a sense - and a relationship with change
and the ability their ability to
translate that and make it you know
functional activity or make it impact
within within the nonprofit the last
thing I think that is important is I'm
amazed in the nonprofit world I've
always been amazed in the nonprofit
world at the lack of leverage amongst
the kind of industry group you know in
the nonprofit world even today it
they're basically silos they're
basically silos and it seems to me that
one one idea that I would strongly
recommend in in board governance is that
you have the executive director of some
other nonprofit on your board and that
you've worked that you asked your
executive director to go on some other
nonprofit point you know in business
it's almost universal that you're on at
least one other board and the preference
is to have at least one or two
presidents of operating companies on
your board you look at you look at the
board
you look at the nonprofit boards I'll
wager it's less than 10% that have
someone who's on another board and yet I
think it's very important because there
is a lot of leverage there are a lot of
you know one of the easiest ways to
improve your capability is to steal a
good idea you know you don't have to go
through any of the pain or agony it's
already been proven you know all you do
is pick it up and carry it along and as
a board member I think it's important
it's helpful if you're on a couple of
boards because then you really can do
that you really can steal ideas
and bring them and have them apply and
then the last thing I think that that
board should be sensitive to and it's on
the same theme as collaboration and that
is that there is leverage in
collaboration you know in our company we
look at markets and we look at the
ecosystem of the market who are the
players who are all the players that are
in our space and then we figure out how
we can leverage all of those
capabilities so that we get not just a
return on their dollar we invest but we
get those are my observations I'll leave
it there pass it on to my colleague good
evening it's a pleasure to be here I
must say that I was figuring out how my
batting average was going to look after
John and bill went through sort of the
must-have requirements and I'm just glad
to see that so far at least on John's
list I'm batting two for three so it's
not too bad even if you consider that
I'm thinking about cricket and not
baseball
in addition to being here amongst an
unlikely group of similar people I like
sitting amongst lefties and I'm sitting
between two and I'm one myself it's very
nice feeling I'm perhaps the the only
representative of a non-profit
I mean board members who serve on
nonprofits here but as CEO a nonprofit
that not only works primarily
internationally but perhaps the only
representative right now who serves both
I see you on as a board member on an
organization that is consciously
feminists dare I use that word and I
hope that as I share some of my
learnings as CEO you might find that
there has been some advantages and some
lessons learned and derive both from
that philosophy and practice as the
women's movement said many years ago the
personal is political and I would add
perhaps also a professional I'm going to
talk about the three C's that I've that
I'd like to share at this meeting just
from my perspective booth is having
served on a number of nonprofit boards
but I'm going to speak with my with my C
and my CEO hat on in this in this few
minutes that I have the first C is
communicate caring for any organization
like the Global Fund for women that
works in 160 countries and has 14 board
members eight of whom live and work
outside of the United States this is a
basic requirement be able to communicate
communicate communicate and to do so in
a way that communicates a concern and a
caring and an appreciation of your board
members sharing information sending
updates taking time to reconnect when
you actually see each other it's not
just nice feminist practice it also
turns out to be extremely effective for
making sure that the work happens so
some examples of what I found to be very
helpful in this regard
part of what will referred to the Global
Fund actually not only manages to bring
the people whom we serve through our
grant-making to visit and meet with
board members but in fact we have as
board members representatives from those
organizations themselves so the women
who are on our board from developing
countries are often either former
grantees or members of our broader
Advisory Council some things that we do
to try and make sure that we stay in
touch during the time that we are far
away from each other we meet only twice
a year the board needs twice a year
because they have to fly in from any
different possible I provide the board
with monthly email updates our CEO I
make a special effort to share special
accomplishments of the staff and of
individual board members recently one of
our board members was nominated to a
fairly significant and senior UN
position she was very shy about sharing
this news but I was in a position to be
able to share that news with the board
more generally and with our staff that
was something that was an appreciation
of caring gestures of appreciation again
maybe this is unique to a women's
organization I would argue that it's
good practice for nonprofits people who
serve on your boards do so at no cost
for the most part except as both bill
and John mentioned a deep interest and
commitment to the issues it doesn't hurt
to show your appreciation send flowers
to the board member who spent extra
hours helping you complete your
strategic plan offer a gift gift
certificate of appreciation when
somebody has taken the additional time
to work with staff on a particularly
difficult budget review process to make
sure that you weren't presenting an 18%
growth rate or whatever small gestures
like that don't cost a lot of money but
they do communicate caring and concern
and I think that they can be very
effective ways in which you can sort of
build a community on your board that
that really makes a difference a few
other examples that we use at the Global
Fund because many of the people who
serve on our board
are not in fact wealthy philanthropists
themselves and yet they work as board
members on an organization that gives
away over five million dollars a year in
grants to women's rights groups we offer
outgoing board members the chance to
award a grant of their own to a group of
their own special concern or involvement
as a gesture of trust and respect it has
to meet global fund criteria but it is
something that they can make to a group
of their own choice we've also made a
special effort to link alumni board
members so that people who go off the
board also receive updates from myself
as a CEO ongoing information about what
key decisions have been made by the
board opportunities to come back and
reconnect with people who they've you
know had connections with in the past
and that's that's proven to be very
helpful my second C is constructive
criticism one of my best lessons as a
relatively new CEO and the Global Fund's
Board of the of the Global Fund for
women came from a comment made maybe
three years ago by my Board Chair
Jacques Elina Pechanga who's a leading
feminist in Brazil and has been on our
board as board chair for the last two
years she asked why is there so much
applause at Global Fund board meetings
is this an American practice and then I
I sort of I you know I initially I
wasn't quite sure what she meant and
then she went on to explicate that she
felt that does the staff feel that we as
a board are simply here to listen to our
multiple achievements and to applaud
them because you know the reports that
john was talking about you know we don't
see them except twice a year and we sort
of feel we have to roll out our multiple
achievements in this that and the other
the Development Report the marketing
report all our fabulous materials and
and there is this sort of environment
and created in which sort of the board
members have to sit back sort of with
glaze depreciation and then sort of
applaud at the end of it
she urged us to think about a different
design she said you know such a format
of a board meeting makes us feel unable
to listen to what it is you really worry
about what's on your mind where do you
need our help where is our expertise
going to be helpful to you and I think
it changed for us as soon as I could
hear that not as oh it's a critique of
how we run the global fund but really
from a place of this is constructive
criticism that could really help us run
these meetings in a much more effective
way I think we were able to change our
board meetings around so that we were
able to get the best value of the time
of the board members who in fact do have
extraordinary expertise on a number of
different issues and could have been a
resource to program staff and others and
fundraising staff and finance staff had
we really been able to go and say you
know we're working on this knotty issue
and we'd really like to spend a couple
of hours talking with you and getting
your feedback so constructive criticism
something that you should be both
willing to hear as a CEO without your
defences up which is I think an initial
reaction of many of us because we think
we work so hard at these nonprofits and
we just want our accomplishments to be
on review but also being willing to
provide constructive criticism when we
when we feel that might be necessary in
terms of kind of board performance and
their ability to respond to issues and
my last see courage of conviction
nonprofit organizations have often been
referred to as the independent sector
independent that is of either government
or the private sector our do-good hats
require us to work from a place of high
moral conviction where we place a high
premium on certain principles and values
at all times but maybe particularly in
these times where patriotism is defined
by lack of dissent and where we defend
Liberty by detaining people indefinitely
it should be I believe the role of a
board of trustees to demonstrate and
embody call
values and the courage of their
conviction which goes back to the issue
of a clearly defined mission if in fact
you are an organization whose mission it
is to see the world as one entity shared
by all of us then it must be the board
that lives up to that courage and
demonstrate and embodies that courage of
conviction and then in turn enables that
to continue to have the nonprofit feel
that its mission is clear and consistent
even through difficult times at the
Global Fund we have found that the
wisdom of that collective conscience if
you will that is housed in our Board of
Governors has really served us well
resulting most recently in a thoughtful
and very balanced statement on world
affairs that helped us negotiate and
navigate relations both on the one side
with 2,000 grantee organizations in 160
countries many of which were not feeling
particularly warmly towards the United
States or organizations based in it in
recent times and at the same time to
balance and negotiate and navigate our
relationships with a primarily us donor
base who was seeking to engage with the
rest of the world in a manner that was
both respectful and non defensive and I
think again in this we were helped
greatly by being able to look to our
board to demonstrate the kind of courage
of conviction and clarity of their
understanding of the mission of the
organization and I felt again in my role
as CEO that that was a place where I had
much to learn from sort of the
collective wisdom of the board thank you
Bob thanks Bill there was a couple years
ahead of me here at Business School and
I guess one of the big regrets I have is
not going to work for him after he
recruited me to McKinsey but we all end
up on the same panel anyway
I was a 1980 graduate of the business
school and I left Business School and
had no nonprofit experience and I was
lucky enough to be invited to go on the
board of the Bay Area Discovery Museum
which is over on rince Marin County side
of the Golden Gate Bridge it was the
first board experience I had and it was
a great experience it was a startup
board it was a local board it was small
there were older mentors available for
me which was a wonderful way to break
into the nonprofit world and I think
that as as board members join it's it's
critical that they're indoctrinated into
the board and the way of that particular
board because there's a lot of culture
in each and every board that's made up
and I gained some developed development
experience which is critical as all of
you know for any board what worked
through a capital campaign in 1992 I was
invited to go on the board of the
Natural Resources Defense Council NRDC
which is a national policy and advocacy
environmental organization and I had no
environmental background at that point
in time but I did have an unrecognised
passion and I think passion for a board
member is a critical component that
board just for all of you is about 40
members 25 attend the meetings and six
to eight do most of the work so it's not
that different from some of the things
bill talked about and I headed a
committee they're looking at
institutional strategies I was really
brought on the board because there were
few business voices on that board and
they felt that they needed a different
perspective and John spoke a bit earlier
about perspective and it was through
that that I began building knowledge
around the issues of of the environment
in 1996 I went on the board of the
Golden Gate National Park Association
which is a local board involved with
support for the GGN ra there about 30
board members there attend do most of
that work I've been involved there in
strategic planning and in 1999 enjoyed
the board of Conservation International
which is an international group that is
working to protect the Earth's
biodiversity I've been involved with
long range planning there there about 40
board members 20 attend 10 do most of
the work so through my experience I've
found that I wanted to give you a little
background about where I've where I've
been and the work I've done has mostly
been institutional in nature and
organizational and planning and focus in
terms of board governance I guess I'd
just like to start out by saying that
good good governance starts with great
people and in the end if you have great
people on your board it's a pretty
obvious thing and those great people
need to be harnessed their energy needs
to be marshaled but if you start out
with the right raw material and you can
motivate that raw material through
leadership I think you're gonna have a
great board it could be - mentioned her
three C's I have I guess six six E's
that that make up the personal qualities
that I think are necessary for a board
member and many of these are obvious and
they're true for nonprofit boards as
well as business supports ethical board
member must be ethical they must be
energetic they must be endowed well
doesn't have they don't have to be but
that's certainly a benefit to the
organization they must be empathetic and
there's a big difference between a
non-profit board and a for-profit board
and the way that the board members
relate to the institution I think that I
was reading an article about the sort of
the ineffectiveness of business leaders
when they serve on nonprofit boards and
I think it's very important to
distinguish between the the way that you
approach a non-profit board and the way
that you approach a for-profit board
because the people working at the at the
not-for-profit board are there for very
different reasons generally than the
ones that are at the for-profit board
and the two last E's our effectiveness
and expertise and I really feel business
experience is a very important quality
and John talked about the understanding
of continual change and certainly in the
world we live in today all organizations
need to continually reflect and and look
at themselves and how how they can
change to make themselves better
concerning board governance I really
see that there are sort of soft issues
and they're hard issues and the soft
issues involve the feel and style of the
board bill talked a little bit about the
size and the makeup and there's no right
size but I think that the board has to
reflect the chairman the chairman has to
be a strong leader of that board and the
executive director or president of that
institution and the the communication
and the style and how those two people
work together has the potential to have
enormous impact on how that board how
that board is governed those two people
together with the with the nominating
committee really shaped the board and
again John spoke about the grid that
everybody that it's important to look at
diversity of background and perspective
as you're putting a board together
boards can communicate in many different
kinds of ways they can communicate
either formally or in a very open
fashion I find the most effective boards
are the ones where there's good
discussion at the board and not just a
series of present one presentation after
another if you're going in to listen to
presentations you can really do that
today on email or any other number of
other ways to communicate but with the
with the executive director and what the
chairman of the board need to do is is
marshal the talent of that board to gain
a perspective on a critical issue that
that that institution is is laboring
over and I think in the end there's two
qualities there that are you just can't
have you can't go without our courage
and empathy and again that sensitivity
to the nonprofit world that I talked
about but again as bill mentioned which
is really true a few great people can
make a huge difference on a board
without those few great people the board
will really not be effective and
ultimately I think the institution will
flounder there are other hard issues
concerning board governance and many of
these issues are the same issues and
footing in the not-for-profit world that
are faced that we're facing today in the
for-profit world we're not that far away
from the enactment of the sarbanes-oxley
Act I hate to bring that up and
group but those kinds of reforms are
going to be coming down the pike in the
in the not-for-profit world as well and
it's interesting because of all the
boards I've sat on we've had finance
committees where we've looked at how
we're going to invest the money and
we've looked at the budget but we've
never had audit committees and I think
that from my perspective having an audit
committee having a control perspective
on the board both in terms of skills as
a board member but also in terms of the
way that the board looks at at their
duties their fiduciary duties to the to
the stakeholders in that institution
having an audit committee I think today
is something you really can't can't do
without and having the skills of
understanding a county and control are
much much more important today than I
think they have ever been in the past
because of the visibility that nonprofit
boards have in terms of committee
structure in terms of sarbanes-oxley and
some of the ramifications of that I
think internal controls code of ethics
you know it really should go without
saying that the people that are working
for an institution or ethical but I
think unfortunately we've seen with
various different scandals that there
are times when when even nonprofit
boards lack a level of ethics that uh
that they should have and so I think we
will ultimately be forced to institute
codes of ethics Institute certification
of the financial reports and ultimately
I think there are aspects of the
sarbanes-oxley that will add to good
governance as long as you don't as long
as these institutions don't sort of get
clobbered by bureaucracies so we've got
to balance the you know bureaucracy and
processes with creativity and passion
and certainly on that that is I feel the
same way about a for-profit board that I
do a not-for-profit board and if you
don't have a good balance I think we're
that institution will ultimately be in
trouble but in the end it's about people
it's about great leadership it's about
leadership with the executive director
and it's about leadership with the
chairman of the board that really goes
about building the
to reflect the institution